please join me in welcoming to the couch
uh Dave and John from Dynam Mighty guys
welcome to the show glad to have you
here uh counter spy it's a game that
folks on gam SWOT have gotten some a few
looks at before but it's out today also
we're giving some of them away uh so if
you want to go ahead and retweet
gamespot's tweet about the giveaway and
follow Gamespot you can win some counter
spy codes you guys generously provided
uh but dude your your game's out today h
all right how are you even like
controlling yourself enough to sit still
on the couch this must be so exciting
for you it's such a great feeling I mean
we've been working so hard on this for
over a year and a half now and so
finally to get it out and put it in
front of people and let get some
feedback from what people think about it
it's just such a great feeling you know
a little bit of relief but also a lot of
excitement a lot of excitement and so
we're playing on PS4 now and but you
guys are also on PS3 and PS Vita yep
that's correct uh it's Cross by and it
has cross save uh cross save capability
music to my ears Absolut do you guys get
like Danny you get excited as I do when
you hear that cuz it's just it's like a
deal breaker sometimes really yeah
completely I'm really L it's it's not
it's like when it's like when I hear
that it's got cross save I'm like okay
yeah I'm in it's like cuz my TV like 10t
away from my bed but that 10t is a big
difference when it comes to like like
just wanting to be in bed and doing it
on the V so yeah yeah nice work putting
in that extra that extra effort cuz not
enough people do it very cool it's the
best you just have to have TVs
throughout your entire house and you can
do it that way as well right I tried to
do that g those dark old days think of
all the counter space you can free up in
wall space counter space for counter
spot counter space for counter spot all
right so uh we're playing as uh a spy in
the counter organization I don't know if
we have a camera angle that can check
the the wall art in the back you guys
add it on but uh it's on there we we'll
get it get a look at it uh but this is
you guys are you guys really leaned into
and are big fans of that sort of' 60s 7s
Cold War era and that and this this
stuff almost looks like propaganda art a
little bit like well um yeah we kind of
uh I guess one way that we've described
it before is it's sort of um a little
bit of our love letter of to The
Incredibles mixed in uh with a little
bit of bond and kind of a dash of ducts
of strange love um and the propaganda
angle is I guess something that um so
Mark who our director um really brought
to it he went crazy on like when you go
throughout the levels you'll see all
these sort of posters and all the design
around the world um and because we kind
of focus this on you're you're you're
going into both superp Powers right like
you're not uh um a us or a Soviet agent
um or in our world the the superpowers
are the imperialists and the Socialists
right um and so you're this sort of
Rogue agency that's breaking into both
of them which one is the
Socialists well what do you think we
could have a long discussion about that
yeah actually we can get real deep on
geopolitical stuff here uh but I'm not I
I can't read Russian does this actually
say stuff in Russian or you guys just
make like it is Russian okay it is
Russian you don't know the is you're
tell me Google Translate tells us it's
Russian excent I'll just get yeah hold
up my phone to it get some translation
going it'll be good would you refer to
this video game as a 2.5 d game is that
fair or is that super
reductive um yeah sure two 2 and a half
D I guess um I think what does it mean
CU that's what made it pop out to me the
first time I saw it was was seeing all
this stuff well I think that the thing
that we kind of got excited about was um
so of the inspiration is very much our
our love for sort of classic arcade
style Sid scrollers right um but because
we're building it out in 3D uh we kind
of realized that we could open up the
combat space a little bit bit more and
have these cover points um where you pop
into cover and the camera shifts around
so yeah I think that to your point about
the 2 and 1 half D I guess that's a a
good way of describing it that's
something a games journalist would say I
suppose exactly perfect we'll go with it
yeah I mean we just love the way that
you know with 2D side scrollers you can
have a fairly simple control scheme but
then when you can switch into the 3D
camera like this we can still set up
pretty cool dramatic angles like this
and so you know you can have sort of a
little bit more of a kind of almost Cati
type setup that but you're not sitting
there having to control the camera
yourself it's like you know we do it for
them basically and that is kind of a
neat way of amplifying that sort of
cinematic uh appeal that kind of you
know the the dramatic angle of oh Jee
awesome ragd doll there
nice he's now just a permanent fixture
in this bunker exactly uh what's your
mission coming in here then cuz I notice
a lot of like collectible stuff in like
hidden areas and whatnot right yeah so
um um because basically the both
superpowers are trying to uh launch
rockets at the Moon they're sort of in
this Race Against Time and you're trying
to stop them so throughout the game
you're you're looking for the launch
plans like that your your main goal is
collect all the launch plans so that you
can uh uncover one of the locations go
there sabotage the rocket uh but along
the way there's a lot of hidden areas to
explore and discover stuff um there's
things like blueprints that you collect
and that's how you'll complete your um
you'll unlock weapons uh dossier there's
lots of little Collectibles um I just
actually also wanted to draw your
attention cuz John normally doesn't play
as well as this I was going to say two
head shots back to back he's actually if
you look in the top right of the corner
there's a stealth combo that he has
going that's actually a pretty cool
Advanced uh sort of way to play the game
so for people who are diving into the
game now um sort of earning currency in
the game particularly as it gets harder
like that becomes more and more
important um you'll find Intel in the
world and things like that um but also
um the stealth combos will be a big
points multiplier the more people you
can sort of stealth kill in a row uh
adds up to more points and then you get
more cash at the end you kind of your
agent Bonus Goes Up oh nice SEC out
there John uh is there also like a do
you guys have like a leaderboard uh that
sort of that also surfaces on yeah we've
got uh leader boards and and we also
have a kind of a cool little feature
where there's this rival spy mode so uh
once all your friends are playing and
you're seeing their scores on the
leaderboard the game will start giving
you um a friend score for that level and
uh as a Target and then if you can beat
their score and sort of best it then on
the next level you can go find their
agent and then you'll get more points
more
cash but you can go find like their what
find their agent what do you mean by
that so basically
uh you beat their score and then on the
next level um their agent is hidden
somewhere in the level their down agent
so if you can find their down agent in
the level you can kind of get the Intel
off of them and then you'll get some
extra cash oh interesting they show up
as a sort of an extra objective yeah
it's like instead of just chasing your
friend's leaderboard and going oh I beat
your score it's just a little extra
Easter egg where you can actually go out
um look around if you find the agent
then you'll you'll also get some extra
extra cash for your game I think this
might be my best stealth I about to say
like you're you can see you like just
being extra careful now as well fixed
yeah so I should say I'm like the
engineer on the team here and so I often
end up spending a lot more time kind of
staring at like some gnarly bug rather
than actually playing the game so it's
kind of fun to sit down here and dive in
of all days for you to excel John yeah
today is that day exactly when the
pressure is on huh uh so I guess sort of
the the way you're moving through the
levels uh it seems to be sort of uh you
know once you get to a to a certain you
know area this board this you know
between these two sets of doors do you
just kind of clear that area move on to
the next area and then progress that way
do you ever have to sort of backtrack or
anything like that no it's uh the the
John sort of playing in a methodical way
clearing the room and that is generally
a good way to play um the the levels are
all stitched together procedurally so
rooms get reordered and
so if you started playing game again you
wouldn't see the same levels um and so
generally you start out on the left and
then you're kind of moving in One
Direction um there are areas where there
there's a little bit of branching so
there's like elevators and you can go
down and there's sort of alternate paths
that'll lead you to extra stuff um and
there's also a lot of hidden areas but
um generally like the way that excuse me
John's playing right now he's also doing
a good job of managing the Defcon which
is the number that you see in the middle
of the
is Curr
at I think he noticed his friend head
missing didn I can't believe you might
actually finish this level I don't want
to ched
it I was so close now I can start having
so we might actually see um one of the
guys get on the radio but basically um
the defcom will go up uh based on how
much the enemy sees your presence of the
world right so if they see you they
might start getting on the radio so
there's a dude right now he's radioing
in that's causing the death gon to go up
oh yeah I see the meter security cameras
if they spot you that'll cause the death
con to go up um and also if you die
there's a penalty um and so that Defcon
p uh level is something you kind of want
to be managing throughout the game and
it also is consistent from level to
level so uh if it gets too high then
they start a countdown and they're going
to launch and it that way way you've
just got to book it to the end of the
level oh great and try and abort the
launch it's only now I appreciate how
difficult the head shot are that you've
been like nailing them the entire time
it's a little tougher when they're
throwing bullets back at you but yeah
yeah cuz it's not a game about just sort
of waiting in I mean you're not you're
not able to take much damage that defc
con is going to go up fairly Speedy but
are you so but here you completed the
mission the meter went down so even
though it it does sort of is a through
line from mission to Mission there is a
way to to reset it a little yeah but if
it went up to like two and then to one
like it won't go back down oh I'm a bit
croaky once it hits the threshold and
change his number it won't re go back
down from that number it won't go back
down but you can uh get it to go down
and one of this is where one of the key
uh strategies you need to deploy in the
game is uh officers in the game they're
pretty cowardly lot if you see an
officer hopefully we'll see one in this
next level yeah you should definitely
play an imperialist level um
yeah if you see an officer in the level
um uh you should take out all his
friends so that he's all on his own and
then if you can aim your weapon at him
um he'll surrender and then he'll
actually call in and uh lower the death
everything's cool over here guys oh
we're fine y ship shape no need to be so
alarmed yeah so it's it's kind of a key
part of the game is is managing that
level and it's one of the things um at
one point we had just a great Countdown
the whole time and you're sort of
running against the clock but it's one
of these things during game development
you're always trying different things to
see what works and what doesn't we we
kind of realized that it it kind of took
a lot of the fun of the exploration out
of the game and if you're always
worrying about that clock going down
you're not really going to take your
time to like wait for hide wait for a
dude to come up and then you know
stealth kill him you're just going to be
running um and so this this sort of
really helped stretch that out it still
gives the players something to manage
and keep an eyee on a little bit of
pressure right but then once that
countdown starts then you know okay now
I've got to kind of book it and get to
the end explosives are your friends
that's great you named one after me a
guys so sweet there you go when we go to
IGN later we have a we have a special
one with like Greg in there as well
yeah you guys know your audience here
easily pandered to uh I'm a little
worried you just went through that door
it said no spies through there um is
that going to be a problem whates
they're not really big fans of us so you
know what does CRA stand for uh we might
run a competition and maybe people can
guess what it is that's our clever way
of saying we we did have um we knew what
it meant once did you lose done so many
late nights on this game to get it done
it's locked away in some part of our
brain somewhere yeah it actually is on a
document somewhere night you're just
going to sit up in bed at night and and
just like recite the entire so here's an
officer he he actually hasn't seen you
so what you should do John is switch to
a noisy weapon don't mess it up John and
don't shoot him don't shoot that Barrel
it's so tempting though oh
we any other situation I would always
say shoot the barrel so he spotted me
there you go and they make him surrender
until the deathcon goes up there now
shoot the barrel all right all right I
wonder if this no it won't will that put
the death back up oh he should probably
get out of there oh
well great you're not allowed to take
out surrendered officers they once
they've surrendered the Geneva
Convention exists in this game as well
their lives are over anyways you don't
understand yeah he's going to have to go
back and report to a superior Commander
now so oh there's a barel all right all
right maybe I'll just get bit more so
aside from like the you know from
looking as slick you know as John here
you know that's a that's a motivation
for stealth uh the point system stuff
like that is there uh you know you
complete you you you stay stealth you
complete it you get more money to help
then like upgrade your kit was that it
come on John you're not playing all
right sorry listen so yeah so you can
basically uh you go through you find
blueprints which will unlock new weapons
uh you find formulas which give you kind
of boosts like onetime boost for for
that level um and then there's also
dossier which give you a bit of the sort
of backstory of the world of and the two
superpowers um and uh then as you play
through the levels you know you're both
trying to unlock those things and
collect cash which you know once you've
uh found all the blueprints for a weapon
you spend the money to buy those new
weapons not just pistols all day no so
we've got a few kind of fun weapons that
you can upgrade as you go on through you
know sort of more powerful machine guns
um we have a mind control weapon that
gets the uh the enemies to kind of
attack each other and so mind control a
few other fun ones there that people can
find as they play through the game yeah
the the game it gets progressively
harder the further you go there's more
Elite guards you know take more damage
stuff like that so some of the earlier
weapons will lose a bit of their
effectiveness so something like the uh
the Mind Control gun is awesome cuz you
can take if you can get one of the the
really tough guys with that oh man oh
you killed the officer
Dave I don't know my chance you're
supposed to be better than me Dave
thought that's why you brought John
along D he's the ace um if I'm trying to
talk and play though John so you
here consult your multitasker John knows
I'm not a multitasker
so you should he'll try and talk to me
when I'm working like are you what did
someone say something um what was I
saying I don't know but I like how this
it was super interesting whatever day is
kind of going the other way here with a
bit more of a sort of aggressive playr
and so you know the game definitely
supports both the play Styles you know
if you just want to go in use the
explosives have a bit of fun you know
are those the hats coming off or their
faces it's the hats it's a tated game
right okay but it's really the faces
right that's wishful thinking I think I
know we did have blood running down the
skin in the last game but you know this
one is definitely for the youngsters as
well um yeah what was it saying oh yeah
that mind control gun um yeah good
Strate for for later on um when you get
those tough guys that come out and
they're super hard to kill shoot one of
those guys with the Mind Control gun so
now he becomes a bullet sponge for his
friends they all turn on each other and
then sometimes you can just sit back and
let them kind of enjoy the B out check
your tweets real quick exactly hey what
going look up over there all right we're
clear hey cool uh speaking of tweets we
have some winners Twitter uh some
Victors uh who are going to be getting
counter spy codes and I'm going to ask
one of you kind gentlemen if you would
mind reading out the four names they
guess the name of counter no we didn't
make it that hard for them but uh here
are the winners uh of counter spy codes
all right number one is hyper flood all
right hyper flood hyper flood have fun
uh number two is NM
rain making a rain what do you think NM
stands for need more
more uh farmer X Matrix gaming yeah sure
SS like name of and the final one is
Alvin
Princessa congratulations each and every
one of you fantastic got for your way
it's available today on the PlayStation
Store correct yeah exactly wins it out
in Europe uh it goes out yeah later on
same time tomorrow so probably like 3 4
in the afternoon cool European time I
think it just went live around now
actually PlayStation store so oh man y
very very cool uh do you guys do you
have any other Platforms in mind a PC
release somewhere down the way
interesting might so uh so today it's
available on PlayStation 4 PlayStation 3
and Vita M uh but we do have uh IOS and
Android versions coming all right so um
those are it's not the exact same game
but it is interesting because it has a
lot of the same core gameplay you're
still an agent you're sneaking through
levels doing all your sort of spy stuff
so actually pretty excited about that
and it has cross save
yay everyone making games take not as
well absolutely take a note out of these
gentleman's book cross on everything so
your progress is transferred across like
your actual levels you play through are
a different so you can't transfer that
part but all the uh the blueprints
you've unlocked and the formulas they
transfer across um and there's even if
you link it with your PlayStation you uh
you can find some extra kind of weapons
that you wouldn't be able to get on
theall game by uh L them together so by
them
all